[Musique]
certains seront peut-être les aviateurs
de demain ils ont entre 13 et 18 ans et
sont mordus d'aviation ces adolescents
font partie des escadrilles air jeunesse
un programme immersif de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace pendant plusieurs
semaines l'équipe du journal de la
défense a suivi Tom
Alix
Manon
et Ryan
des jeunes qui au fil des mois vont
confirmer une vocation naissante et
prendre leur envol
[Musique]
Ryan en rêvait volé à bord du Piper l4h
un avion militaire utilisé par l'US Army
sur tous les fronts de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et lors du débarquement de juin
44 un rêve devenu réalité grâce à son
escadrille beaucoup de sensations de
dessus
puis on peut voir qu'un avion des années
40 quand même c'est c'est incroyable de
le voir restaurer ainsi et puis voler
dedans c'est un privilège je pense
on les surnomme les équipiers eagent
ils sont 700 à vivre cette expérience
unique
répartie sur le territoire national
[Musique]
en outre-mer et à Djibouti pour eux
l'année est ponctué de rendez-vous
sportifs et culturels à la découverte du
monde de l'aéronautique l'Armée de l'Air
et de l'Espace s'est inspiré du modèle
anglais des cadets de la Royal Air Force
objectif et te fait la passion de ses
adolescents avec en toile de fond un
soupçon de cadre militaire
à droite
Ryan intégrer le dispositif en avril
dernier année de création de l'eaj
d'Angers
grâce à mon collège donc il y avait des
des pancartes on va dire des petits
flyers où il y avait marqué qu'il y
avait que les escaliers argenèse
ouvraient à Angers donc c'était par
l'armée de l'air et puis ça m'avait
intéressé vu que forcément j'aime les
avions depuis tout petit et puis
découvrir l'armée de l'air avec ça ça me
passionnait je peux je me disais que ça
va être une superbe expérience du coup
j'ai postulé et puis j'ai été pris Ryan
n'a que 13 ans et demi et se familiarise
déjà avec le garde-à-vous il prend
doucement ses marques encadré par le
capitaine Christophe
la militarité elle reste à bas bruit on
leur fait pas un stage garde-à-vous
repos parlant trois jours et forcément à
cet âge là pour les plus jeunes quand la
semaine il parle monsieur et quand ils
arrivent ici il y a c'est difficile de
ce Recorder pour mon capitaine
Christophe a plus de 35 ans d'armée à
son actif après avoir gravi les échelons
il a terminé sa carrière comme formateur
au CPA 10 une unité des forces spéciales
aujourd'hui réserviste opérationnel
c'est lui qui donne le tempo à Angers ce
qui m'a surpris la première fois c'est
la volonté d'engagement la passion de
ces gamins pour pour l'aéronautique
alors pas uniquement l'aéronautique
militaire mais tout ce qui touche à
l'aéronautique ils sont très calés
là-dessus donc nous on leur apporte
parce qu'on a un référentiel bien
l'histoire de la grande tique l'histoire
de de l'Armée de l'Air enfin des jalons
importants pour qu'ils étoffent cette
connaissance supervisé par la Direction
des Ressources Humaines de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace le Centre d'études
stratégique
et l'école de l'air et de l'espace
toutes les eagg ont un programme commun
on a quand même un cap une sorte de
bible si vous permettez qui nous permet
de savoir où on voit qu'est-ce qu'on
quels sont les matières les le timing
qu'on doit faire on essaie de respecter
ça au possible mais chaque agit à son
terroir et c'est pas toujours facile car
un Angers il n'y a pas de base aérienne
le agit a donc noué un partenariat avec
l'Espace air passion le premier musée
d'aviation légère civile et militaire de
France un mercredi sur deux ces
équipiers rencontrent des bénévoles
passionnés comme Dominique ancienne
official à retraite
lorsque nous avons été sollicités nous
avons été très vite conquis par ce
projet avec
la spécificité du patrimoine
aéronautique sachant qu'il y a bien sûr
des matières si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
qu'il socle mais également il y a des
matières optionnelles et cette
présentation du patrimoine comment on
restaure un appareil la partie
documentation la partie
menuiserie mécanique électricité et
ensuite aussi maintenant pour que
ensuite perpétuer la remise en vol de
ses avions
c'est un grand bonheur parce que tout
petit déjà donc j'étais passionné
d'avion et puis c'est vrai que
si on veut laisser une trace il faut
transmettre bon ben en colonne par un on
s'approcher parce que l'idée de
manoeuvre c'est de remonter ce bel objet
cette année Ryan a participé avec son
escadrille à la rénovation du Bréguet
904 un planeur construit dans les années
il faut bien qu'il y ait des personnes
qui tiennent mais surtout pas parler les
volets uniquement par les parties fixes
d'accord donc pour empêcher de basculer
c'est surtout ici et puis la partie
supérieure ici
et ce mercredi c'est l'heure de
l'assemblage final il faut porter des
ailes de 10 mètres pour les accrocher au
fuselage de l'avion une opération
délicate
on y va 1 2 3
jeunes comment on fait pour garder le
suivi de cette machine la mise en croix
le contrôle des gouvernes tout ce qui
est donné par le constructeur auquel on
reste très rigoureux comme comme
autrefois j'ai toujours rêvé de montrer
ce que je savais faire non je l'ai dans
la peau et je la garde jusqu'à la fin
[Musique]
elle est pas totalement mise
encore un petit peu
[Musique]
direction Évreux ou l'une des toutes
premières escadrilles a été créée en
2019 sur la base aérienne 105 ce
mercredi ses équipiers se déplacent en
ordre serré pour la toute première fois
et ce corps donné comme des militaires
cela ne s'improvise pas
à chaque fois donc il me faut une
première rangée donc vous êtes en ordre
décroissant il me faut les plus petit
devant donc vous allez vérifier vos
alignements après on va vous donner
toutes les instructions
[Musique]
le jour de gloire et impressionnant
c'est impression de se déplacer
beaucoup de monde mais comme si on était
qu'un en fait je sais pas comment le
dire mais
c'est ça c'est impressionnant tous le
même pas le même et la même forme
surtout
Alix à 15 ans depuis un an il est membre
de l'ehj d'Évreux à sa tête la
commandant Laurence réserviste
opérationnelle cette professeur
d'histoire-géographie n'a pas hésité une
seconde à s'engager dans l'encadrement
de 55 équipiers j'ai une passion pour
l'aéronautique depuis toute petite donc
moi quand je vois un avion décoller j'ai
eu le cœur qui bat la chamade
donc je pense que même mon rêve le plus
intime c'est de passer mon brevet de
pilote l'aéronautique plus
l'enseignement la transmission escadère
jeunesse ça fait tilt
on est là pour faciliter pour que ses
rêves se réalisent en tout cas leur
montrer la voix on est un petit peu
voilà comme sorte de fenêtre un petit
peu sur tout le monde aéronautique sur
la base parmi ces jeunes nombreux
convoitent un poste dans les métiers de
l'aéronautique et pour certains l'avenir
se dessine déjà dans les airs c'est le
cas d'Alix mais aussi de Tom 17 ans sur
le tarmac le rescadrille rencontre un
pilote chevronné de Casa un avion de
transport militaire sur la plupart des
avions militaires vous allez retrouver
cette disposition c'est juste pour des
raisons de praticité vous rendez bien
compte que pour charger ou décharger
rapidement un avion c'est plus rapide
avec une grande allée centrale dégagée
qui avait que les petites allées
des pistes sa mère tout à fait la
sensation et c'est juste que c'est un
petit peu plus lourd on a l'impression
de d'atterrir moins dur et si moi c'est
compliqué non c'est pareil c'est en fait
ça demande un énorme travail de
préparation parce que il faut s'assurer
qu'on a le droit de s'y poser que
l'avion va pas s'enfoncer qu'on va pas
le détruire l'avion en essayant de se
poser à cet endroit là donc ça demande
un travail en amont beaucoup plus
important c'est une fille enfin c'est un
avion militaire on passe souvent dans
cockpit d'ailleurs il y a un pilote qui
les explique donc c'est encore mieux et
c'est intéressant on peut se projeter
dans l'avenir se dire peut-être que plus
tard je serai dans cet avion ou même un
avion plus performant donc ça donne une
certaine idée de ce qu'on veut faire
juste le transport mais je pense que je
vais prendre le transport si je peux
pour rejoindre une agie nul besoin de
vouloir s'engager ou d'être issu d'une
famille de militaire il suffit d'être
féru d'aéronautique et ultra motivé pour
déposer un dossier de candidature
ils sont moins il y a des groupes de 3
des groupes de 4 à 18 ans Manon et
l'aîné de l'aventure ce mercredi elle
encadre les plus jeunes lors d'une
course d'orientation
manon a intégré le ajdrule il y a trois
ans sans aucune connaissance du monde
militaire et depuis la lycéenne porte un
tout autre regard sur l'armée au début
c'était très très impressionnant on se
dit waouh ils font ils sont militaires
ils font peur vraiment ne serait-ce que
d'aller sur base militaire ça fait peur
au début ils vont en guerre c'est des
personnes importantes et nous défendent
elles ont des armes aussi mais en fait
au final on apprend un petit peu à les
connaître il y a vraiment toujours le
respect le respect des encadrants etc
depuis toujours Manon veut devenir
avocate mais il y a quelques mois grâce
à son nœud agit elle a fait une
rencontre déterminante pour son projet
professionnel
j'ai pu rencontrer l'astronaute
claudieigneré la première femme
française à être allée dans l'espace et
donc bah c'est grâce à elle du coup que
je sais maintenant que je m'oriente vers
le droit spatial à l'avenir c'est un
milieu qui est en pleine expansion dont
on n'a pas encore quand on exploite pas
encore toutes les capacités et vraiment
c'est une révélation dans ma tête il
fait je veux faire du droit spatial et
j'ai plus la recroiser justement que le
dénurait je lui ai dit merci parce que
c'est grâce à vous que maintenant je
sais ce que je vais faire
toutes les semaines Alix fait 40 minutes
de train pour rejoindre Évreux avant de
grimper dans le bus qui l'emmène sur la
base aérienne ce que les gens est
originaire de Mantes-la-Jolie avec un
père ingénieur aéronautique et un
grand-père colonel Alix à baigné dans
l'aviation
en devenant équipier il touche son rêve
devenir pilote de chasse
plus fort
toute l'année des cours magistraux avec
en ligne de mire l'obtention du brevet
d'initiation aéronautique
au programme météo
histoire de l'aviation sécurité en vol
et anglais aéronautique
là c'est le centre d'examen pour le BIA
ça devrait aller un petit peu stressé
mais ça doit aller pour espérer
décrocher son biia Alix doit obtenir une
moyenne de 50 points sur 100 pendant 3
heures il va plancher sur des épreuves
théoriques un premier pas décisif dans
l'aéronautique
au niveau des tables
des sacs
en tout cas bien mais à côté de votre
table s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
certaines questions j'hésite encore un
petit peu mais sinon c'est très bien
passé
à part un petit peu navigation je suis
pas sûr mais normalement
aérodrome de Toussus-le-Noble dans le
département des Yvelines l'objectif
premier c'est ben déjà vous êtes là pour
ça une découverte de l'avion électrique
donc un avion électrique qui est
totalement identique à un avion
thermique et comme ça va être c'est
quand même un de vos premiers vols les
eags ça va être le deuxième objectif
c'est un bol d'accoutumance c'est un vol
d'instruction donc vous aurez total
liberté de
manœuvrer l'avion au sol de décoller
l'avion de piloter en vol et d'arriver
jusqu'à l'atterrissage
après la théorie place à la pratique
pour Tom et Alix
n'a jamais empêché un avion de voler
j'allume la radio le transpondeur
parfait on a 520 pieds c'est bon 500 que
Nash 1015 très probablement on va voir
ce qui nous dit à la radio d'accord
c'est parti pour 30 minutes de vol grâce
à un partenariat entre la fondation
el-de-france et la Fédération Française
d'aéronautique
[Musique]
les différents d'un avion moteur essence
les sensations sont similaires mais pas
tellement par exemple au décollage qu'on
est sur un avion essence c'est le plus
de bruit ça livre plus il y a un peu
plus de sensations alors que sur les
trick bon c'est plus calme ça y est au
moins il y a moins de bruit mais quand
même l'excellation est quand même là
reste près toujours présente c'est
extraordinaire enfin de voler donc oui
c'est très content la fin du vol bon
souvenir
ce jour-là Alix a pris les commandes
pour la première fois
[Musique]
il a décollé l'avion il a roulé l'avion
au sol il a décollé l'avion il a piloté
ensuite
l'avion il s'est même posé également
donc un bon futur pilote
on le récculte les valeurs de l'aviateur
quatre valeurs phares le respect
l'intégrité le service et l'excellence
les quatre lettres font le mot rise le
mot rise en anglais c'est c'est s'élever
c'est à la fois s'élever mais du quai
mais c'est aussi s'élever décoller comme
un avion donc vous voyez que il y a une
symbole une symbolique derrière qui est
intéressante et c'est aussi leur
apprendre les valeurs de l'aéronautique
découvrir le monde de l'aéronautique
découvrir le monde de la vie en
communauté et quoi de mieux que le sport
pour forger le sens du collectif
assez simple les équipiers sont
justement en pleine séance de frisbee
pour le week-end de l'Ascension très
œufs agissent sont réunis pour un
challenge national
[Musique]
des efforts récompensés les jaunes
occuperont la troisième marche du podium
[Musique]
ce matin le rendez-vous est donné à 8h
sur la place d'armes pour la levée des
couleurs en immersion ces jeunes civils
touchent de près aux traditions et aux
coutumes propres armées
à commencer par la coiffe réglementaire
un calot couleur bleu nuit
de quoi nourrir un sentiment
d'appartenance à la communauté des
aviateurs
de la beauté
[Musique]
on les a formé pour ça aussi donc non
non toujours très solennelle et toujours
des moments un peu voilà émouvant et
toujours la fierté aussi donc c'est vrai
que je devais des couleurs voilà donc
c'est pourquoi on est là
le 14 juillet Manon et Tom metront en
application ce code de bonne conduite
sur les Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
quand même de se dire que j'ai pu en
arriver là grâce aux escadrières
jeunesse et ça me fait
c'est une grande responsabilité qu'on
nous donne mais je suis vraiment très
contente de pouvoir participer à ça et
c'est un honneur vraiment de pouvoir
participer au 14 juillet
il est tout juste 6 heures
nous retrouvons Manon et Tom pour une
répétition dans les conditions réelles
sur la place de la Concorde votre numéro
vous pouvez vous faire équiper
directement cette année les oeufs agit
participent à l'animation finale du
défilé et pour ce cru 2023 la résistance
est mise à l'honneur à l'occasion des 80
ans du Conseil National de la Résistance
le coussin de la résistance du groupe de
bombardements de Bretagne donc c'était
des un groupe d'aviateurs résistants qui
ont aidé justement à libérer la France
et on fait diverses batailles en Afrique
aussi
le 14 juillet Manon présentera la
décoration de ses bombardiers devant la
tribune présidentielle aux côtés de 150
jeunes
tous chanteront la Marseillaise avec le
cœur de l'armée française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial on sent quand on passe au
milieu de la musique on est envahi par
cette émotion c'est incroyable vraiment
et puis de représenter aussi le coussin
comporte c'est très fort
c'est une grande chance c'est la seule à
représenter l'armée de l'air je suis
également la seule escadrière jeunesse a
porté les coussins donc c'est vraiment
un grand honneur d'être là c'est la
seule sur le gâteau pour mes toutes mes
années de
Lycée Militaire de Saint-Cyr 5 heures du
matin
le défilé a lieu aujourd'hui il ne reste
plus que quelques heures à Manon pour se
préparer
Cléo vient lui prêter main forte pour
former le chignon parfait
[Musique]
mais ça va bien se passer c'est ce qu'il
faut se dire
concentration de rigueur pour Manon et
ses camarades et dernière mise au point
avant d'entrer en scène
c'est bon l'insigne je vérifie bien bien
parfait on s'est préparé depuis plus
d'une semaine à se réveiller aux aurores
et donc l'un le grand jour est arrivé
donc vous avez fait ces répétitions avec
sérieux avec une grande rigueur moi
vraiment je vous félicite on est
vraiment très fiers de ce que vous avez
pu accomplir on est vraiment stressé
mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit que rien
rien peut venir nous perturber parce
qu'on est vraiment calé
[Musique]
c'est parti on se retrouve sur les
Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
la soif d'apprendre chevillée au corps
ces équipiers sont les visages d'une
jeunesse volontaire et passionnée tous
sortiront grandis de cette expérience
[Musique]
changer d'esprit avec le respect la
cohésion la discipline tout ça ça m'a
fait évoluer depuis depuis un an en fait
j'ai découvert plein de gens
découvert plein de gens j'ai fait des
bonnes rencontres
puis c'est tout le côté passionnant
c'est passionnant que des choses que
tout le monde peut faire encore une fois
on voit des choses que tout le monde ne
voit pas forcément
très c'est magique on peut dire que
c'est magique et
extraordinaire encore une fois être tous
ensemble ne pas avoir peur des autres
avoir un fort esprit d'équipe c'est
vraiment les les racines des USG
[Musique]